vous avez évoqué deux trois fois et puis
ça nous a même fait sourire
conjointement benalla il a fermé nahla
mais jusqu'à la sphère benalla la
majorité parlementaire à l'assemblée
nationale
on se croyait les maîtres du monde c'est
bien que vous le dise je les dis
plusieurs noms que j'ai aucun problème
avec ça je vous avais jamais entendu le
dire je trouve que c'est bien on se
croyait les maîtres du monde
rien ne pouvait nous résister et la
machine s'est déréglée
on a beaucoup travaillé on fait des
erreurs on a beaucoup travaillé plus de
la moitié de mes collègues n'avaient
jamais fait de politique donc un monde
un monde à découvrir avec ses règles ses
codes et autres et à partir de ce moment
là quelque chose a déraillé
voilà et mais nous collectivement
députés de la majorité
on se croyait intouchable et
irrésistible et ça fait à quoi parce
qu'on avait gagné parce que des gens qui
n'avaient jamais fait politique en six
mois se sont retrouvés députés moi j'ai
été élu la première fois en 1995 j'étais
maire 15 ans je suis toujours conseiller
départemental depuis 20 ans même si
j'aurais sans doute été candidat dans
l'ancien monde tu voyez ce que je veux
dire puisque j'étais suppléant mon
prédécesseur mais tout ça je les
construis donc là ne vous a pas tant des
les construit patiemment je veux pas
dire que ça a tourné la tête de mes
collègues c'est que le monde politique
il a ses règles particulières il est dur
et un certain nombre de mes collègues
qui venaient d'autres horizons
on cuit tout dominique parce qu'ils
avaient été élus contre des personnes
qui depuis 30 ans faisait de la
politique etc et est donc on a péché par
excès de vanité collective
voilà bah écoutez c'est très bien
d'avoir la même j'ai été lui aussi enfin
mr en tous les cas en 1995 nous voyons
fait partie tous les deux de l'ancien
monde
je pense qu'il ya aussi quelque chose
quitte enfin moi qui me qui m'étonnait
quoi on a eu l'impression 2017 que
l'expérience l'expérience qui est
valorisé partout dans le monde
professionnel
la big apple une tare dans le monde
politique c'était incroyable ça mais
l'expérience c'est aussi ce qui permet
jrv d'avoir une vision peut-être plus
précise de la situation de l'opinion de
la manière dont on peut réformer le pays
ou pas voilà donc je suis heureux de
vous entendre dire cela aujourd'hui et
j'espère effectivement que on va entrer
dans une phase un peu différente quoi
pense que bon de l'autre côté je parle
pas opposition majorité mais pour tous
ceux qui sont engagés en politique
depuis longtemps et qui le font pour
servir le pays avec leurs convictions
cette espèce d'arrogance qui consistait
à nous renvoyer comme ça aux oubliettes
de l'histoire
bon c'est un peu difficile à vivre